it is all five time again which means
I've got the best five stories of the
whole gaming week already ticker for you
here's the important
south of 2014 game awards are happening
shortly and the nominees have been
revealed there's a heck of a lot of
categories but the games in the running
for Game of the Year are bayonetta 2
dark souls 2 dragon age inquisition
hearthstone and middle-earth shadow of
Mordor on top of that Nintendo turns out
to be the most nominated publisher with
12 and treat all our nominees were
picked by a jury of 28 international
media but let me know who gets your vote
highly anticipated space flight sim
elite dangerous is making some people
unhappy this week by announcing that it
is dropping its offline mode the mood
was promised in its Kickstarter campaign
but has since been abandoned due to the
need to cure it and evolve the galaxy
according to frontier developments CEO
David Raven executive producer Michael
Brooke adds the problem is that the
galaxy mechanics all set only online
servers the data set and processes are
huge and not something that would
translate offline without considerable
compromise to the vision has also been a
bit of a problem since wild refunds were
offered those who played the alpha or
beta can't get their money back
presumably their participation meant
that they had an internet connection
lost screenshots and info from
blood-borne have landed in our lives
this week and here's the new stuff we've
learned about from software's upcoming
creation we got to look at a new
character cog EULA who is described as
an old veteran hunter who said to
possess amazing skill and there's also a
glimpse of a location known as Kane
hearst castle in regard to this one
producer misaki yamakawa teased what
happened to the family that ruled this
castle for many generations what secrets
and what dangers await you there the dev
also highlighted a weapon called the
transforming cane which is a sword
disguised as a walking stick that also
transforms into a blade width
and civil weird stories of the week
which let's face it always seemed to be
the best stories and office wants to
hang out in virtual reality for 28 days
mark farad is calling the project seeing
eye and plans to wear a VR headset for
24 hours a day to see through someone
else's eyes and into their life ferid
plans to be on display to an audience
the whole time in a space that only
consists of a beds toilet and shower
area he's also asking for 150,000 pounds
on Kickstarter to go ahead with this in
order to pay people to keep in the lab
and functioning to develop the
technology to broadcast what the other
person is looking at and to ponder
documentary about the whole thing the
campaign is currently raised 4,000
pounds is a very all we do' you decide
nintendo of america president Reggie
season may has said rather
unsurprisingly that he thinks the Wii U
is better than the xbox one or the ps4
he's charging that the wii u gives
gamers the best value with popular
exclusives like mario kart 8 and super
smash brothers for Wii U he went on to
say that the console differentiates
itself further with amiibo support fiza
may explains the good news for us is
that we're presenting the best value
right now in new home consoles 299 bucks
includes two games it's a compelling
proposition to consumers this holiday
those two games are super mario 3d world
engine in sunderland which come with the
32 gigabyte base preview model as for
your question of the day let me know
which console or bundle you reckon has
the best value for money this holiday
season and if you'll be picking one up
as always thanks for hanging out this
week i'll be back with more news on
monday but be sure to have yourselves a
lovely weekend adventuring in dragon age
far cry or whatever else you have going
on
you